we've evolved to experience things
in this
3d world
and it's that's a very rich experience
when you're thinking mathematically
uh you still in the end of the day have
to project it down
to a
low dimensional space to make
to make conclusions their conclusions
will be a number
or a line
or plot
or visual
so i wonder like how we can really touch
some deep truth
in this in a subjective way like
experience it really feel the beauty of
it you know in the way that humans feel
beauty
right are we screwed
i don't think we're screwed i think that
we get a little hints of it from
from
psychedelic drugs and so forth we get
hints that there are certain
interventions that we can take on our
interface
i apply this chemical which is
just some element of my interface to
this other
to a brain i ingest it and all of a
sudden
i seem like i've opened new portals into
conscious experiences
well that's very very suggestive that's
like um the black body radiation doing
something that we didn't expect right it
doesn't go to infinity when we thought
it was going to go to infinity and we're
forced to
propose these quanta
so
once we have a theory of conscious
agents
and this projection just based on i
should say i should sketch what i think
that projection is um
but then i think
we can then start to ask specific
questions when when you're taking dmt
or you're taking
lsd or something like that um
now that we have this deep model that
we've reverse engineered space and time
and physical particles we've pulled them
back to this theory of conscious agents
now we can ask ourselves in this
idealized future
um
what are we doing to conscious agents
when we
apply 5mu dmt what are we doing
are we opening a new portal
right so when i say that i mean i have a
portal into consciousness that i call my
body of lex friedman that i'm creating
and it's a genuine portal
not perfect but it's a genuine portal
i'm definitely communicating with your
consciousness
and we know that we have
one technology
for building new portals
we know one technology and that is
having kids
having kids is how we
build new portals into consciousness
it takes a long time can you elaborate
that oh oh oh you mean like
your son and your daughter didn't exist
that was a portal though you're having
contact with consciousness that you
never would have had before but now
you've got a son or a daughter you had
you went through this physical process
they were born then you
there was all the but is that portal
yours
so when you have kids are you creating
new portals that are completely distinct
from the portals that you've created
with other consciousness like can you
can you elaborate on that to which
degree is are the consciousness of your
kids
a part of you
well so every person that i see
that symbol that i see the body that i
see is is a portal
potentially for me to interact with with
a consciousness yeah
um and
and each consciousness has a unique
character we call it a personality
right and so forth so with
each new kid that's born we come in
contact with a personality that we've
never seen before and a version of
consciousness that we've never seen
before at a deeper level as i said the
theory says there's one agent
so this is a different projection
of that one agent
but but
so that's what i mean by a portal is
within my own interface my own
projection
can i
see other projections
of of that one consciousness so can i
get portals in in that sense and i
so and i think i think we will get a
theory of that that we will get a theory
of portals and then we can ask how the
psychedelics
are acting are they actually creating
new portals or not
if they're not
we should nevertheless then understand
how we could create a new portal right
maybe we have to just study what happens
when we make when we have kids
we know that that technology creates new
portals
so we have to reverse engineer that and
then say okay could we somehow
create
new portals de novo with that
with something like uh
like uh brain computer interfaces for
example yeah so maybe just a chemical or
something so probably more more
complicated than a chemical that's why i
think that the psychedelics the
psychedelics may because they might be
affecting this portal in certain ways
that it turns it around and opens up
in other words it may be once we
understand what this thing is important
your body as a portal and understand all
those complexities maybe we'll realize
that that portal can be shifted and into
different parts of the the deeper
consciousness and give new windows on it
and so in that way maybe yes
psychedelics could open up new portals
in the sense that they're taking
something that's already a complex
portal and just tweaking it a bit
well but creating is a very powerful
difference between
morphing right right tweaking versus
creating i agree
but maybe gives you intuition to at
least the full space of the kinds of
things that this particular system is
capable of i mean i mean the idea your
idea the consciousness creates brains i
mean
that breaks my brain because
because uh i you know i'm i'm i guess
i'm still a physicalist in that sense
because that you could
it's just much easier
to intuit the world um it's very it's
practical to think all right there's a
neural network and
what are the different ways
fascinating
uh capabilities can emerge from this
neural network uh
it's free it's easier and so you start
to
and then present to yourself the problem
of okay well how does consciousness
arise how does intelligence arise
how does
emotion arise
how does
memory arise in the how do we filter
within the system all the incoming
sensory information we're able to
uh allocate attention in different
interesting ways how do all those
mechanisms arise
to say that there's other fundamental
things we don't understand outside of
space-time that are actually core to how
this whole thing works
is uh is a bit paralyzing because
it's like oh
we're not we're not ten percent done
we're like
0.001 percent done
it's defeat
certainly understand that my attitude
about it is
if you look at the young physicists
who are searching for these structures
beyond space time like amplitude and so
forth
they're having a ball
space time that's what the old folks did
that's what that's what our the older
generation did
we're we're doing something that really
is fun and new
and and
they're having a blast and they're
finding all all these new structures so
so i i think that we're going to um
succeed
in
getting a new deeper theory i can just
say what i'm hoping with the theory that
i'm working on i'm hoping to show that i
could have this timeless dynamics of
consciousness no entropic time
i take a projection and i show how this
timeless dynamics looks like the big
bang
and the entire evolution of space-time
in other words i see how my whole
space-time interface
so not just the uh the projections just
doesn't just look like space-time you
can explain
the whole with it the whole from the
origin of the universe that's that's
what we have to do and that's what the
physicists understand when they go
beyond space time to the amplitude and
the cosmological polytube
they ultimately know that they have to
get back the big bang story and the
whole evolution that whole story where
there were no living things there was
just
a point
and then the explosion and then just
particles at high energy and then
eventually the cooling down and the
differentiation and finally
matter
condenses and then life and then
consciousness that whole story has to
come out of something that's deeper and
without time and that's what what we're
up to that's we we want to to get this
so the whole story that we've we've been
telling ourselves about big bang and how
brains evolved in consciousness will
come out of a much deeper theory and and
for yeah for someone like me um
it's a lot i mean um
but for the younger generation
this is like oh wow
um all the low cherries aren't picked
this is really good stuff this is really
new fundamental stuff that we can do so
that i can't wait to read the papers of
the of the younger generation and i want
to i want to see them
you